I think we're good what if I just like
come slightly hey guys I'm Ryan right
then I'm Katie do bot uh Katie do ba is
Batgirl today do your Batman voice Katie
hello we're watching reviews today it's
like Bart Simpson trying to be tough
it's Sarah but I mean I deserve the best
you're working on it guys I'm sorry
so this is a trailer we're gonna check
out today is Batman Arkham Knight Gotham
is mine
trailer I've seen all the ACE chemical
once katy has not seen any footage of
Batman Arkham Knight yet and some guys
don't know this but she likes games
actually
so yeah let's check this out you're
ready Katie these videos are pretty
[ __ ] awesome okay excited I love
Batman
it started with me
everyone was there therefore study
etiquette that together we could take
you out and Gotham would be ours over my
dead body
that was the idea sweetheart
Brendan's of God I have messages for you
all to the Vandals who stayed behind to
pick this still warm flesh from governor
bone have you thought you are under my
protection
to the cow is clicking behind the police
department wall looks like that support
you not fair
to Batman
major city was the violent optimum if
you were a little with safety you
provided with words
when the dog come
when optimizing room and I turned my
gaze to the world beyond that's pretty
bitchin that was awesome that was
awesome
I'm keeping it on guys can you know this
seems really Dark Knight Rises inspired
like about a villain and who is taking
over to Gotha flight has just suddenly
seized control of Gotham and you know
the bad guys are running free now crime
and you know it was also about taking
down Batman and how Batman will show no
symbolism and Gotham anymore yeah yeah
The Dark Knight Rises with scarecrow
scarecrow well which was kind of the
next step and of course yeah we just
introduced scarecrow a movie and so that
does make sense natural progression
comes full circle if that was linked
unfortunately it's not but if it was
linked that would be cool but I think it
is inspired a little bit more because
you know the other games did have
cinematic features to them and there was
cinema but this one seems really like
story driven this time around yeah which
I like about that I've seen a lot of
cinematic trailers for it so by seeing
that you're like oh they're really
promoting a story right now it is pretty
scary it's like it turns Batman into a
dark knight because now he's just
[ __ ] pissed and any yeah yes I take
on the world yeah yeah he has to take on
everybody I mean the whole city of
Gotham is basically going down oh yeah
that's horrible anarchy Anarchy
introduced a little join the anarchy to
fight the inner key to defeat a monster
you must become the monster which is
kind of what Batman's whole thing is
that was beautiful embracing his fear
you know he's already done it I think
Batman's gonna win in the end what if
there was a game that by the time you
won your
character still lost and I don't be sad
be the most unrewarding game anything
there's no way to win just can't anyway
guys thanks for telling me that video is
out if you're new to the channel you
know what you can do you can subscribe
if you have a computer there's a button
right up here Wow what's this button
check out Katie's boss Joey says I said
I don't know Alison Katie Katie the jail
very very it was me flying away in the
bat-signal yeah alright very good
Machado improv right there yeah check
out Katie's channel there's a lot of
sketch comedy on there so yeah check it
out yeah yeah we're good looking on that
see we're good on the promotion yeah
thanks
quick and dirty I'm gonna start saying
this now because I've actually been
using these lately follow us on
Instagram Twitter and Facebook mainly
Instagram I use that more than anything
else
sweet Twitter's I'm gonna follow you on
Instagram you should be following me
already
I'm not an instagramer so I don't become
an instagramer
to be with the hip kids okay yeah you're
gone with it you're halfway there right
now so good job Kenneth Carrasco I
posted this in the wrong place anyway
okay can I get a shoutout Ryan you make
amazing videos you are funny as well as
the other rejects Sally Veronica and
Alyssa are hot and Katy is not mentioned
there I find you attractive as well Ryan
thanks he's a bisexual subscriber thanks
man thanks for the laughs and great
content
you mean content because you like dick
and [ __ ] that's what's awesome about you
my friend bisexuals they get the best of
both worlds buttholes from guys vaginas
from girls maybe a bubble from a girl
throw down for it but nowadays it just
seems to be a porn thing I don't really
see it a lot of girls I know I've tried
it and don't even like it so ya know
what's going on
that man attacked me that that is what
happened man doesn't like anal jokes
apparently